welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz and today
I'm joined by Rob Hanna who is the owner
of cusine car got it right got it right
on that flat two minutes Rob so thank
you and so yeah Rob we are in they said
set the scene so we're in a boardroom is
this this is a meeting room in what
street we're on we're on one King Street
one King Street so right by Bank really
nice offices yeah we're very privileged
to be I have to say yeah very nice
offices and just off cheap side so yeah
those nights yeah cool so and that's
where we are today but as I was saying
and Rob where I always love to start how
did you get into agreement the golden
question and you probably haven't heard
this response before but I always didn't
wake up one day thinking I was going to
be a recruiter yeah now I fell into
recruitment very much so I was actually
got a call from a wreck to wreck whilst
as at University and I thought they were
pitching me a job for Procter & Gamble
they were talking about sort of
marketing advertising sales and kind of
really sold this role to me thirdly the
dream and and anyway I sort of stumbled
along King William Street and found
myself further recruitment firm
interview and very much from there I I
quickly learned about the industry and
and fell into it but the honest answer
is I was very much given a call by
Rectory a host University and and fell
into it wasn't something that I had
initially considered and with a degree I
did a business management degree with
French French is somewhat possible now
at best
yeah but yeah that's what I did at Leeds
University because it was one of the
time a good university for employability
on the business school and some of the
top did you always want to go uni
it was I guess it was um you know
following a levels it was something I
was really keen to try and pursue not
just so so from the sort of academic
perspective but I think from the sort of
social perspective and the general
character so I'm from Leicestershire
originally and that was one of my
passions for setting up the casino car
because my grandfather ran a I'm a very
successful law firm in the 1950s called
rich in car solicitors so I always had a
passion to kind of emulate his success
okay in business well we're definitely
get into that yes exactly
okay so fell into recruitment rhetoric
called you you had no idea what that was
going on and then from when I look to
your LinkedIn you ended up at the
infamous s free indeed yeah so I had you
know good time at s3 I joined you
therefore so I was there for 18 months I
probably joined a very interesting time
shall we say I joined in the 2008
Lehman's crash so you know first day
foot through the dual I'm seeing people
carrying PCs you know seeing people sort
of you know walking in and out of the
office frantically screaming Lehman's is
going down Lehman's is going down you
know head head head hyung and that meant
nothing to me at the time you know I
didn't understand I barely had a
training crash course at that point but
it really kind of chucked me in at the
deep end and you had to kind of learn
your stripes and I have to say s3 was
really good at kind of the fundamental
basics with training of recruitment and
my first manager at the time really kind
of looked after me and sort of put her
arm around me at the time because there
was a chance where you know there was
going to be redundancies the market had
been so I've I've actually diversified
across four markets started originally
in oil and gas in the engine space yeah
I did that for 18 months and then
following that and that was a good
experience my boss actually left to join
a business that he was a director in a
boutique business and had a very good
relationship with them and I kept that
sort of relationship and I always wanted
to sort of explore I'd been in a big
global environment the recruitment
industry and I wanted to try something
different and say he sort of suggested
coming to join them so I did and that's
sort of how I made my my sort of first
move so before we get before we get into
that quickly and what I always just like
to sort of and try and understand and
cover I think I said to you before we
spoke and did this but and what what
really and
plot and seed to start this was just
just my experience in the first year it
was extremely difficult and extremely
tough and so how were you how was your
first four months in recruitment so I'm
very open to people in saying I was very
much a first-year flop okay I didn't
take to recruitment naturally whatsoever
and I think that's and that was quite a
shock to me because I'd always been sort
of in sports teams you know played it
quite yeah not an arrogant way but
always thought I was confident about
myself so I thought you know this is
easy it's just finding people jobs you
know which we all know it's not there's
a lot more to it so yeah I was a I
struggled I really kind of didn't grasp
the basics as quickly some of the other
people would you know my general
qualification skills my meeting skills
you know my understanding of my market
and how to get good at the job you know
really shadowing the top villas really
learning from them by osmosis you know
all those things you should be doing I
wasn't really doing and so I wasn't you
doing them was it did you faint used to
did you think like was there was there
an element of not having humility at
that point and for you knew better or I
just think I wasn't I didn't stop you
know it one thing was I wasn't as
focused as like looking back on it now
you know the way I plan my days yeah I
was very reactive I was going to work I
thought I was doing well but I wasn't
getting the results yeah yeah and you
know in that environment you are
targeted on targets naturally um and you
know I wasn't kind of billing what I
should have been billing so you know I
was lucky that I had a supportive team
at the time that sort of said do you
know what they backed me because I think
it could have gone the other way was you
doing the right activities may giving it
giving it a go I was doing the
activities but I probably wasn't doing
them to the standard that was needed to
to really build because you know you
meet some people who were you know
wonderful billers in their first year it
really cook up I'm genuinely not that
case so when you say was a flop what did
you building pleasure
I probably build about a hundred 100k in
my first year that isn't that bad my
first year how much have you been very
open 24k
there's no way I'm blaming the market
that scenario it was it's just really
difficult man I think so I recruited me
in the insurance sector yeah and I was
in the business of between eight and
twelve people and I I basically just did
everything that my the people around me
told me to do hmm and the thing is why I
didn't lose my job was just simply
because I i sat next to the owner of the
business and I was I absolutely worked
my socks off yeah in that first year
like it wasn't an element of not
listening thinking on you better these
things and and they just kept sending me
Hisham keep doing what you're doing and
doing the right activities it will pay
off and they're also you may have
experienced know when you're hired for
your business which we'll get onto but I
really experienced that tipping point
and but yeah my that's that I mean 100k
in your first year isn't the end of the
world had a target of around sort of 160
contract it was permanent so I've always
mainly been permanent I'm an element of
contract as well but yeah so in in my
eyes of the people that I was working
with you know I was sort of laughs way
off target yeah and you know I joined s3
as well at a time because it was a big
brand you know you're surrounded by top
top billa's you know hot you always want
to push yourself to be the best in my
opinion
and so yeah III I know I was surrounded
by people you know who are billing you
know five six hundred or people who have
got sort of in a hundred runners on a
temp desk you know and it's lucrative
and really impressive people yeah
exactly
the next part then I'm always just so
fascinated by asking sort of this whole
s3 environment what it was just because
now moving to so I used to recruit in a
small business as I was saying inherit
eve so outside the London and then
obviously moving to London and I've been
exposed to this sort of whole world of
recruitment in London right and
obviously is a huge huge huge brand yeah
so I'm just just before we move on I'd
love to sort of get from you going from
not knowing what recruitment was in
these things to then being in an
environment that so many people speak
highly of enhances and so many and
successful people what was your
perception and the experience of working
in in the s3 environments you just
mentioned a bit of it there but was how
would you describe the experience
that that whole time I think s3 was a
genuinely great experience and from my
cohort as well there's probably 10
business owners just a loan from I
started with so it's true what I think I
enjoyed about s3 at the time was they
really do focus in on training I mean I
didn't know you know recruitment isn't
rocket science people can dress it up
however they want it's not it's
simplifying the job I didn't know what
an open question was when I first
started I didn't know how to effectively
qualify you know and they really do work
you to understand how to get good at job
so I was very lucky in terms of they
invested in me in terms of sort of
formal training and I was very grateful
for that and then they also give you a
lot of opportunity to get involved so
and they put you in a team and they kind
of really do push you to do as well as
you can so I think my really nice tan
yeah it's high standards and I think
that's what I enjoyed about my time
there but it's I would say the training
of actually going through sub-sub
practice areas of what it takes to be a
good recruiter yeah you know is second
to none and they generally can you know
you'd have catch ups you'd have sort of
progress meetings you'd have targets
you'd have a vision of where you needed
to go so I think the whole makeup of
being in a global company and kind of
being surrounded by top performers but
they're also giving you the platform to
get good at the job really interest a
married together very nicely so I was
actually very grateful for that
experience see it'd be really good
relationship with your manager you said
and then he went off and set up in his
own so he went to join another business
he was a basically become a director in
as well where those sort of you know one
other owner of the business yeah and as
they I kept that relationship yeah yeah
but that was a completely different
sector so I went so all in gassin and
wasn't yeah so I had a year and a half
of oil and gas sort of energy experience
and then I moved into procurement
procurement and supply chain so yeah and
they don't know much about procurement
supply at a time absolutely not new
recruitment now there but I new
recruitment and that's the one thing I'd
say is it the recruitment has a very
good transferable skill set and so many
things that you can get from recruitment
and yeah I joined there and I really
took to it you know as a market that so
how long were you there for just so I
started there I joined there as sort of
a consultant stroke senior consultant
okay
and I was there for the best part of
five years yeah and again I really
enjoyed my time there so I I progressed
I was the first organically-grown
director of the business so from joining
as a consultant very much sort of within
that five year window into my sort of
third and a half fourth year being made
a director yeah and I really enjoyed
that journey it was completely different
to the s3 you know that's three big
global outfit you know everywhere all
the infrastructure everything you would
like to moving to an office where you
know at the time you know we're in the
basement you know and we would I really
enjoyed being part of that power because
I learnt the directors there one of the
directors in particular problem one of
the best recruiters have ever had the
experience of working with really um you
know you could get so close to them and
you can learn from them you can shadow
them and so you know from moving from a
basement to being on sort of you know
Fleet Street move to the office from
sort of you know a few people to sort of
20 30 people you know going on that
journey I really really enjoyed it
of course so let's let's unpack that
yeah I think there's definitely so but
then just just so then I know the the
timelines and just the things so then
and so he was there for five years and
and then was that after there that you
then set up your own real quickly
business yeah yeah okay cool exactly so
before we get into that then five years
and by that by the time we left you as a
director level
you started as a construct senior
consultant and so guess the first thing
and how did you deal with then the
transition of the market because a lot
of people obviously as anyone I think
I'd be the same life I had built up
relationships and people for 18 months
or 12 months 24 months however long to
then chuck that away or wherever you
want to call it to go into different
marketing these things I was that's a
real challenge right because it's pretty
much done from zero again do you go I
mean so how firstly how was that
transition because there'll be a lot of
people listening that may be considering
a move or considering a different market
whatever but that that obviously is a
huge thing to think about so what how
did you deal with that um well I think
firstly I had I had trust I had trust in
the people that I was joining so I
wasn't joining a brand new business in
the procurement space I've been
a very established hi so many important
facts or isn't it so yeah although you
were starting it from zero potentially
but the people that you was working
alongside and supporting had a they they
had complete call desk no it wasn't a
complete cold desk they had built up a
fabulous business and you know worked
day and night to do that and to achieve
that so you know I had obviously had a
previous relationship which which was
helped and I had a trust there as I
mentioned so yeah I but I also a big
part of this in one thing I say you've
got to be prepared to take risks you
know throughout your careers if you want
to kind of push yourself and get to the
the highest level you can get to you got
to take risks and for me I wanted to
exploit a boutique environment I wanted
to take a risk and so I took it and I
put myself out of the comfort zone and I
kind of knew I'd have to kind of really
work ten times harder than everyone else
he's already in that procurement space
to stand the chance and I was prepared
to do that so how did you how did you
start learning about the market
obviously I've got a lot of training
internally but then you've got to read
around the market and the other thing is
we all know your candidates are your
source of information right so getting
back to your point about the recruitment
skills and knowing recruitment prior to
going in with your eyes wide open you
know one candidate can be a source of a
lot of information so though you know I
really at that point I understood how to
qualify candidates I knew how to extract
information I knew how to process that
information I knew how to use that and
part of my own business development
strategy when trying to win clients and
I knew that in terms of how I could use
up my own personal branding and also the
company is very good at supporting you
in terms of getting you in front of
events and getting in front of key
people so yeah there was a lot of kind
of ways but I had to be proactive you
know it didn't come to me I think if
you're gonna take a risk you've got to
be prepared to be proactive and you've
got to be prepared to fail as well
luckily enough you know and I had had
failings I talked to you about my first
year flop I didn't comparatively to
other people around me in that
environment and you know this time I had
to go in as well I had to really go for
it but it wasn't you know was again I
didn't smash my first three months I
took I took to it but it sort of took
sort of three to six months to really
get going and then it kind of kicked in
yeah okay cool so then and then what
what was the timeline of and you being
consolidating consultant and and then
what was the next stage after that what
do you then progress to so then it would
go to sort of prints so every year I
basically manage to sort of hit hit a
promotional target so it'd be principal
consultant manager senior manager
director okay and it was a very you know
it was a very good was it all just done
on billing of course Billings are
important and I think you know we can't
shy away from that you do need to hit
billing targets but I think when you're
in a boutique or in a smaller firm as
well it's important that you're you've
got the interest of the company yes yeah
exactly so you know as you get more
senior you're probably taking on people
under your wing saying you know it's not
just about your billing it's about can
you get others to bill and can you get
them to be developed and can you get
them to improve I think what can you do
for the company generally in terms of
building the overall brand in terms of
actual you know what can you do more to
add value than just being someone who's
okay I'm a director but actually what
else are you doing yeah and it had a
good like sort of family feel to it and
yeah exactly training it like your own
business so Billings you can't you can't
progress with that building that nuts
that's a given
yeah but you need to do more and little
things you know you'd want to hold your
hand up if you want it to be the social
secretary
or if you wanted to you know get
involved in a particular event or if you
wanted to sponsor something you know all
these things if you hold your hand up
and actually add value to the company
then that that's about that yeah exactly
that's so you mentioned about the
first-year floor like how you know how
what was the human that you progress
each time then said that it seemed like
that was a pretty positive pretty
positive experience over those five
years in terms of did you keep hitting
your target Billings increased the
overall performance increased as I say
as I say I think I was surrounded
particularly the owner the company is
one of the best recruiters I've worked
with I think just really knew how to do
good recruitment and never cut corners
never cut corners you know and was very
good at sort of drilling that into
people in terms of how to do
best-in-class recruitment and you know
from little things to making sure that
you know direct dials you knew the
direct dial at a time now it's a people
but all the little fundamental basics
from administrative to influencing to
qualifying
- closing - continuous closing you know
really true all of those skill sets were
really ingrained into you and I think
that was really great to see and really
helped you move from a sort of you know
substandard billet or top biller let's
play that down a bit yeah I'm thinking
people listening make sense but what you
just said there makes you just said that
those things there which he did I just
think that's really interesting and
everything you said resonated when
thinking okay they just made that
crystal clear and unpack that so the key
things there that you mentioned a good
Billa or Grable into a top-class bit low
what what how would you break those down
from what you saw from there from this
chap that Klee was a bit of a mentor to
you and had a big influence on you
well they I think firstly look at traits
in the individual okay and I think the
person that I was sort of emulating
wanted to be part of you know hard work
I think they really were hard working I
know that sounds like a bit of a cliche
but I really were exceptionally
hard-working and committed and had their
own internal drive okay and I think
really to be a successful recruiter you
need to have an internal drive or
internal drive yeah you've got ice
openly admit that I've got a bit of a
chip on my shoulder you know I want to
be you know the best I can be and so you
know I think something that motivates
you have your own goals and an internal
drive that's going to drive you day to
day yeah because I see so many people
what I describe a sort of commute and
coast and so they go to work they do the
job and close the line yeah exactly but
but it's there and everyone can see it
and you know there's there's people in
my sort of networks that I see it and I
tried actually mentor people how to move
out of that mindset actually just
because they're in their job and you
know like well I just got the same bonus
every year it's like well what more can
you do so actually trying to change
people's mindsets it's a work effort so
work ethic for sure I think subject
matter expert really knowing their their
market and how the hell did he achieve
that how did you do that well they
achieved that by basically networking
networking networking networking yeah
they were a key networker a key
networker and then I think it comes down
to fundamental recruitment skills and I
think one of the best recruitment skills
well two of the best recruitment skills
that they had were objection handling
okay an influencing I think we get day
to day
objections you know a top Villa can
learn there was a phrase we had called
learn to love objections and yeah
because so many young recruiters I used
to get scared when I was like there's no
way they're gonna take this salary
there's no way they're gonna do that
location
yeah there's no way two days or weeks
enough for them you know but we actually
created a culture like we embrace
objections you know we learn to love
objections and so we actually had lots
of strategy meetings and we had lots of
discussions about okay let's learn to
love objections let's talk about how we
can get dissect that so we really
understood the objection handling
process and then once you understand the
objections obviously you got to move to
more of the influencing and selling side
of things so again I think what made
them exceptionally good is one of the
best sort of you know objection handling
people and then also one of the best
sort of you know influential people and
sales people and the final piece that
positive is obviously then closing yeah
you've got to be able to close you can
do all the hard yards you can sort of
manage everything manager I think manage
everything but you've got to be able to
close so I think they were the key sort
of things so I'd say hard-working
subject matter expert and it's heck
Nakul skill sets and finessing those
technical skill sets day-in day-out
minute by minute really really important
that's no I think that you put that
really well that's that's really
interesting so I think sharing that no
that was good but this didn't come
overnight either I think it may just be
rolling off the tongue quite naturally
but people actually listening to this
you know as I say I always rewind to
when I first started and even say to the
modern day I'm still learning
recruitment yeah of course and I think
anyone who shuts their eyes off to think
they're an expert in the modern world
particularly a technological advancement
AI and everything that's going on you've
got to be compared to continuously learn
but if you're prepared to learn then you
prepare to but I think obviously I think
is safe to say but if you really double
down on those core things there that you
put together really nicely you have a
really good chance on increase in your
Billings increasing your performance
becoming better and better in your in
your job do you know what I was scared
of when I first started I wish I'd asked
for more is and more help from my
colleagues help yeah because you know if
someone's doing a really good job don't
just look over to them in the office and
be bitter you know be friendly yeah you
know I know this is competitive element
in recruitment for
but actually you know if you built so
build internal stakeholder relationships
yeah
really befriend your cohort and people
around you because do you know what if
they're do a good job you want to learn
from them yeah and there's a thing that
we have internally here that I say to
people is come to work every day and
improve by one percent because if you
improve by one percent every day there's
over 260 of working days a year you know
that's 260 percent worth of self
development every day and it could be
just from a turn of phrasing it could be
to a you know an emotional play it could
be to a tweak on an email it could be
any little thing but if you actually
really come to work every day and don't
commute and coast and be something
different and want to improve you can do
very very well yeah that's that's really
interesting mate so before we get really
keen to get into sort of your your
journey so far with your own business
and stuff but and so really well put
there that you learn from someone in the
business that you really were respected
as human as you quite had one of the
best what best what critters you've been
around so you really try to emulate this
person learn learn from this person
right and so then just to help me out so
then billing wise how do we do here then
like did you continue to improve what
what was what would talk to me a bit
about that because again think of the
people listening and what people want to
understand is that with people listening
that did Bill 180k in the first year or
now in their second version and still
are around that 200 250 hundred kmart
but can't get Braer through that right
so did you continue to up their Billings
and if so let's talk a bit about how you
continue to do that yeah I think yes I
did
so I did it did suddenly click so from
being the first year flock then it did
continuously click so yeah you'd be
going through your numbers and year by
year they'll be going up and you had to
to ensure that you've got the title
promotions every year and but I think as
you become established in a market you
you work smarter you know so the quality
of my jobs you know commitment from my
clients my rates you know all of the
things that are important to working
smart as a recruiter got better you know
had more exclusive candidate
relationships you never had more
exclusive clients and all of these
things amassed to me what I call working
warmer so ok so if you can work a lot
warmer you're going to be able to build
a lot more
because if you're you're still sort of
you know going out there doing lots of
cold DD or lots of cold work then you
know you're still operating at 120 K a
year billing right there's nowhere you
can get better but if you've actually
built up those relationships on the
candidate and client side I have a thing
that we we call here which is sort of
you know inch wide mile deep and you
want to be a subject matter expert and
really kind of you know whichever area
you're recruiting in and at a time you
know as I say it was in procurement
supply chain but break that down into a
sub practice area you want to be the
expert within that in terms of knowing
everyone and really influencing and
working with everyone and so I was able
to do that and so as a result of that
you know my Billings increased year on
yeah okay yeah I'm just curious and I
really like working warm relevant there
that's really interesting so again think
of the people listening I'm thinking
okay so what you said that is really
cool how can I so if I'm right now still
doing quite a bit of cold work on two
years three years in and I'd like to
think eyes do have some sort of
relationships but how did you then we'll
get more warmer work how did you then go
from last year not having as many
exclusive clients or exclusive jobs it's
collusive kind of exit etc so how did
you then start really moving into that
just to break that down a bit more and a
bit more practical sense because I think
I think that'll be really valuable and
because that's what you did right yeah
you can see they're not that then
obviously in correlation meant that your
Billings went up in a lot what was your
best year in those five years so within
the five years so is I have to because
obviously my biggest achievement was I
had to bill I became her overall
director where I had basically over a
million sort of in terms of team and
myself and that was quite a big
commitment yes I was very very proud of
that kind of you know achievement and
then for me from going from 100 K then
sort of one year I think was 180 yeah
250 300 sort of 350 plus and then
obviously you're moving into more of the
kind of team manager yeah and so that
that's really impressive and I know
people would be like okay well how did
you do that and you've already given us
some really good stuff around that so
I'm just thinking yeah as you as you
then sit obviously if you think then I'm
sure you'd look
I'm gone right so this is how I'm gonna
get even more out of that account or
this is how I mean so just just a bit
more practicality around working warmer
I think would be really cool because I I
don't know in my opinion when I was a
junior but I didn't do enough analysis
okay nice an analysis is very important
so I actually had two or three clients
that I was doing deals with but actually
when I was doing more research into the
area
I knew they're gonna have a lot more
appetite to hire okay so I knew I
already had the key decision-makers
on-site yeah that's a chart online yeah
as in that market you needed to be here
to be but you need to have both
so I knew one of the professional
services firms do to research and market
areas was basically going to need to
double in size so I would always every
end of your appraisal I'd analyze which
clients that I really wanted to
penetrate and where I believe is going
to be demand and as a result of that I
could really penetrate them further to
increase my Billings and that made it
attractive to prospective candidates
because if you can paint the story that
you've got a track record and they can
see people that have actually kind of
progressed and stay and equally if
they're going on a journey and you can
communicate that journey and how that
benefits their careers and what they're
looking for so I think a lot of analysis
and that's the whole point I say to
people treat recruitment as over a
career yeah because you're dealing with
other people's careers yeah so if you're
not treating as a career you know how
are you communicating that clear message
to other people and so analysis of my
clients and where there's going to be
demand and then I know where to invest
my efforts because there's no point in
but you know we will talk about work
smart hard work this month where you're
gonna make the money you know ultimately
and then the other thing as I got more
senior was of course I needed to make
sure I passed on my knowledge and
experience to my team members you know
there's a big thing for me and I think
where I want to kind of help raise the
bar of recruitment is to change the sort
of image of you know while it's just you
just finding people jobs or it's a bit
dog-eat-dog or you know it's just like
you know a bit of selling you know
sharing knowledge let's work together
you know I actually do a lot of things
now with friends of mine who are owners
of other recruitment businesses and we
have sort of dual training sessions and
things like that and I think the other
thing for me was yet it's actually
passing on the knowledge to people but
the other thing for people listening in
who maybe
sort of one 150-180 whatever it might be
don't be afraid to ask them more help
okay cool you know I think people just
hide under their desks and worried that
they're not going to hit their weekly
targets or their being and also if
you're not sure that a KPI you feel it's
just been given to you for the sake of
hitting it then if you can justify why
you think that should be reviewed then
go and talk to someone about it because
otherwise there's no I've sat there
before when I was given targets and I
just couldn't get my head round why I
needed to do X yeah yeah so you know I
don't have a discussion about it and so
for people listening in don't be afraid
to up would manage and I think a lot of
I was scared myself to up with manage
when I first started but now I encourage
people in my team up would manage me you
know like think I help people now but
you know don't be afraid to upward
manage because I can help you kind of
get better as well okay so so huge point
there is if you're not if you're not
taking the time to take a step back look
at where you're making your money and
can certain certain client relationships
can you make more out of that can you
offer more of a service can you get more
out of them etcetera etc can obviously
really enable you to no way where to put
your efforts but also enable you to take
your buildings to the next level on
these things right because you don't
need obviously hundreds of clients to
build more do you know if you get what I
mean that no that's quite the opposite
example and that's where people like oh
you know we used to have people say oh
I'm doing some BD today and I would look
at them quite quite shocked when I knew
they had sort of three or four good
vacancies you know with a client that
they should be focusing on but it's like
oh I'm going to be deep that just says
to me that they're not focused okay and
so you've got to be focused you know if
you've got a client there that needs
delivering and you've delivered on it
before why do you not want to continue
developing that relationship and growing
that from sort of you know a small thing
into quite a big thing okay so last
sling then before we talk about and your
own business and the journey that you've
been on what what was some of the souls
you you progress the the typical route
as you said you then achieved a really
big milestone in terms of so how big was
your team in the end or how many people
did you manage so in the end so we had
obviously lots of other sort of managers
within the team as well but when I left
my door
to shitpost I was around sort of 20 of
us in total 22 23
you know from joining reporting to you
indirectly everyone would have been far
as the overall director there with the
other sort of main main director as well
so I would have had responsibility for
that okay which was you know which is
which is great honor you know very very
privileged to sort of got to that that
sort of level but we really worked hard
to develop and get good people through
the door and you know there are some
wonderful billers at the end of the day
mm-hmm so yeah absolutely so two things
that I'd be interested in that just to
get your perspective one and let there
be people listening that are gorillas
may want to do management may not want
to do management but what were some of
the key learnings that I'm sure you
failed that when you start becoming a
manager start getting people under your
wing that you quickly learn that you had
to change your adjuster now looking back
like yeah I'd never manage people like
that again or whatever do you I mean
what are some of the key things around
that and I think some of my management
failures were one I've always been a bit
of a control freak and that's actually a
bit of a bad thing you're gonna be a
manager because you can't you can't do
the job for them exactly you've got to
let people learn from their own failures
you know and that's actually where SEO
is quite good for me I learned from my
own faith yeah pretty quickly so you
know I was trying to do too much for
them you know even if it's from drafting
you know their emails or to you know
listening in to absolutely every call
you know all of those things well
actually you know you take a step back
you've got to allow people to grow and
you know you see all of these things you
know you hire smart people you don't
want to completely sort of take all of
that out of them you want them to bring
their own character bring their own
style because you've gotta have your own
brand so I think for me I would have
kind of let people express themselves
more and you shape and mould rather than
dictate I think that's the thing for me
that I learn you know having been a bit
of a control freak having my own
business you know wanting to build my
own things and I can't you do 300k well
I caught you doing 400k but it's not as
simple how did how did you start letting
go of that then you know I mean what did
you start letting these people do that
typically you would have maybe had an
influence on the other hand fruit like
was it a process or yeah I mean well we
designed you know number of training
once they've gone through sort of
training sessions and they would shadow
do them on and off planet meetings
client meetings
and they'd shown enough then you kind of
almost let them free you know in many
respects and you're there as their
counsel you know they can come to you if
it's look I've got a real issue of
trying to close this scenario or you
know I've got another agency that's you
know battling in on this this vacancy
how can we get more commitment on it
well so it's more of the kind of
technical brainstorming scenarios and
but yeah once you've given them you know
the fundamental basics you've got to let
them run with it and create their own
style yeah I like okay and then the last
thing then before we move on is might be
really mentioned there there and yeah
real one and to be at the director level
see what the business grew to have some
really good people in the business so
like through that process then what were
some of the two things really what were
some of the common sort of pitfalls that
you saw in people that prevented them
from going to the next level right and
then on the flip side of that what when
you did have some really high achievers
in your business what were the common
things that you saw in them I think they
both go hand in hand in advance and the
answer is cutting corners okay because
certain people will be all we're you
know people who can't get to the next
level will you know back to the
objection handling will brush
reservations under the carpet yeah and
everyone's guilty of that and I was
exceptionally guilty of that as well you
would kid yourself I'm gonna close this
deal and they didn't even know the
candidate has other interviews on the go
you know as a basic example you know so
you know I think cutting corners and
being a control freak of your own
business is what you've got to be you
know your own business so you've got to
know everything about your clients
everything about your candidates and be
able to influence them because without
the information you can't do that so I
think people who couldn't progress are
the ones who cut corners so they
wouldn't push to get better commitment
they wouldn't picture retainer to their
clients they wouldn't go and meet their
clients in extra time because they
needed to they wouldn't really qualify
they wouldn't ask the challenging
questions they wouldn't challenge their
candidates because they're afraid of you
know that confrontation element you know
if you're professional and you approach
things in the right way and you're doing
your job for them mmm ultimately and you
know there's no harm in actually asking
the challenging questions and and I
found people the brushed reservations
under the carpet who cut corners and
didn't want a really fun
some improved by that 1% everyday lo and
behold they stay around the 180 and the
200k whereas the real high achievers a
they wanted to improve day to day and
they were seriously committed and they
had excellent control of everything
don't cut corners people don't cut
corners no I really like that so and
have you always wanted to have your own
business then so yeah that it was it was
with a heavy heart reader I left five
years is a long part of your appointment
journey but I always had and this is the
thing I think you need to have is a
passion it comes back to my point at the
beginning of the the podcast that I had
a passion to set up my own business and
emulate what my grandfather did in
believe he was a very big role model for
me yes so he as I say he ran a very
successful law firm in the 1950s
Leicester where I'm from bizarrely was
the second richest city in the UK during
that time due to the commercial and
hosiery trade and so he had a very
successful you know self-made legal
practice that span out across the
Midlands and had one of the largest
outside of any other London law firm at
the time so you know that was real
I had will admiration for that and I
always wanted to and this comes back to
my next risk that I took to want to have
my own business and so I had the passion
but of course I wanted to be good to my
old employer you know I basically didn't
want to go off and compete against
somewhere I'd give him five years of
loyalty to and you know held them in
very high regard so you know I moved
into legal recruitment you know which
all of my friends were sort of
scratching their heads your director
you've got the house everything's going
great why on earth would you want to
move in - let alone set up a business
put your own skin in the game into an
area you don't really know much about
well so that was a big big risk but of
course there's a lot behind that in
terms of research strategy and you know
creating the right plan but yeah I guess
the main drive was a passion and there
was a family kind of emulation and a
legacy that I wanted to continue okay
that's really interesting and then and
then just to set the scene then how long
have you been in business now so now
soca soon car was
incepted in april 2016 so we're sort of
through in a bit years old and yet
growing day by day and it's going
fantastically one right now view and how
many of you are there right now
so the six of us within the business
that currently um we obviously started
with myself and my my business partner
so you started with someone exactly yeah
so and I think another tip for people if
you're thinking of carrying recruiter
into business owner is you've got to
have good people around you yeah and
you've got to have good mental how do
you how the hell did you convince this
person if you had no [ __ ] idea about
legal we were actually we were actually
friends so we were we were friends
previously we'd followed each other's
journeys and basically we were we were
able to sort of sit down and they were
already in the legal market had a set up
they had a retained search business in
the legal market and one of the best
headhunters I've ever met and one of the
best general kind of search people I've
ever had the privilege of working with
and we shared a lot of the same values
so you know I needed a bit of a strategy
when when when exiting so you know I
found a business partner through through
this relationship and from there it's
just grown exceptionally well but I mean
don't get me wrong I've had to work day
and night had to learn the market yes of
course I grew up I grew up in my
grandfather's law firm age 15 doing the
shitty photocopier so I kind of saw what
lawyers did yeah and I kind of knew
about it right and I've always been
interested in the law generally cuz I
think it's such a fascinating market
yeah but yeah that was strategy behind
that so was he so was he on the tools
with you or was he just like that he did
support you to start the business
exactly exactly real support real
support and kind of you know genuine
sort of you know co-founder and real
will help to the business so you know
without that that definitely would have
been a struggle so I'm very grateful for
okay
and I've always big big believer in kind
of team and you know working together
and having the right people around you
and good mentors yeah okay so and fair
to say then it was pretty cold yeah I
mean we're we're basically you know in
one of every markets got it saturated
but legal recruitment you knows a lot of
legal ages so one of the most common
things that people ask me right and I'd
be really interesting to see how you
approach this then obviously you have
the support
and the chuckling talking about there
which is amazing and really smart so I
guess and the most common thing that
people want to understand more about is
also business development right yeah but
two things really which I know what is
one of the things you really want to
touch on so I'd really love to know as
to sort of what your strategy was to go
from yeah those five years really
fruitful relationships yeah now in this
world of legal you've got someone
obviously got a really good relationship
with obviously is gonna add value from
from that side of things surely but
obviously that's gonna be brand new to
you right yeah there's that and then
through that comes with comes the
resilience piece yeah because so how
what was the strategy and how did you
start approaching and building your
client
well again back to my topic of work warm
so obviously through the relationship
that I had you know there was a lot of
color cross referrals and kind of
introductions through that which again
I'm immensely grateful for and and then
research research research you know I
had to kind of get my hands dirty at the
market had to map out the market you
know I'd be reading on Saturdays and you
know if you want to do your own business
unfortunately what it's you can have a
lifestyle business absolutely is nothing
wrong with that but if you want to a
sort of business and to be in you know
the top of your game you've got to make
some sacrifices so you know Saturday
Sunday evenings you know I was
researching you know and I was really
mapping out the market or spotting
trends and I was spotting where we could
actually kind of enter the market and
where we could be different and where we
can add value and and so you know it was
a lot of hard work and you're absolutely
right resilience throughout my career I
think you know having that mental
toughness I think it's really really
important okay because there's always
going to be highs and lows yeah exactly
so before we go on to that Matt's at the
market how the hell did you start
getting clients in so I think again
there was an element of just being
authentic so you know the name above the
door cause soon car actually has a real
meaning and we have a legacy and you
know the fact that I guess it helped
that I had almost got sort of you know
seven or eight years experience as a
recruiter you know I really understood
how to do good recruitment yeah and once
they'd also picked up the knowledge and
you know I'd had these warm contacts as
well and you know I was able to do it
but I wasn't afraid to take risks you
know I'd go sit in front of you know
partners in law firms and be
what sort of you know influence them
through my skill sets that I'd have
because I get tons of objections you
know why should we use you we've never
heard of you
you know what's your story you know why
are you different all of these things
but learn to love objections right so
all of my technical skill set that I'd
learnt from over the years I'd really
worked hard to master I was able to
implement into into my new business that
helped me win clients helped me kind of
grow and develop from there so that's my
point people that recruitment is a very
transferable skill set if you can really
understand and how to actually adopt
those and don't be afraid to take risks
yeah yeah so did you so what was your
approach then to and yeah try and
maximize as some of these crossover
relationships get yourself young his
clients did you go clients first and
then obviously start then trying to
build a network of candidates or no and
because actually and this is a key point
you've got to understand your market is
your market client driven or is it
candidate driven okay and again I'd
actually been historically in more
client driven market really um yeah
whereas the legal market is undoubtedly
a candidate driven market a candidate is
king or queen okay so you know and I
understood that so I understood that law
firms you know law firms are interested
in of course providing excellent legal
services to their to their to their P to
their clients but at the same time
making money right so if you can provide
them is similarly to recruiters if you
can provide them with a good feed
generator a good lawyer then you know is
gonna be appetite for them to buy right
similarly with recruitment firms someone
can send me a great CV of a good
recruiter that's got a proven track
record as long as they fit the cultural
box you know you know no good egg the
likelihoods were probably gonna be
interested in meeting with them so I
really understood you know the market
was a candidate driven market so I built
up my candidate networks so then I can
go and talk to my clients have that
product so I think you've got a way
you've got to be a good headhunter
number one say you've got to be able to
head hunt and again when you say
headland what do you mean by that
so I think because that I've visualized
that I went to seminars McCrimmon I was
a headhunter I mean some my
visualization of a headhunter is and you
said there that the co-founder whatever
was one of the best headhunters yeah you
met aware of it
what does actually mean does that mean
that you're calling people at their desk
tenly if you have this problem I
potentially have this solution for you
let's speak after work what what design
and I think by the way people dress up
the word headhunting that's what head
hunting is an introductory call could be
an email could be a whatsapp it's an
introductory form of communication
that's my definition of head hung okay
okay because people get really scared
it's like we're doing head hunting hour
now and I remember that when I was in
some of back in a day head hunting out
Oh what does that mean I'm really scared
I'm gonna head hunt someone take the
stigma away from it all we do is we talk
to people we consult people and we try
and help people with their further their
careers and we find solutions for our
clients who are struggling with
recruitment I break it down very very
simply so for me it was about having
sensible introductory conversations with
key talent that was a demand for my
whether I knew there'll be a demand for
potential clients and so I can go and
get clients we talking about LinkedIn
messages emails the normal normal lot I
think this is doing that but it's what's
going above and beyond right so I'd know
where key events were I would know where
people were kind of watching and where
people were going because you can't just
be the the transactional unless you're
sending a very and there's nothing wrong
with sending LinkedIn messages emails
and you know but don't just send the
generic email study their profile you
know send a really you know tailored
detailed thought-out substantive message
showing how you can add value okay
because if you can't add value to
someone if you're just saying hi are you
interested in opportunities you're
working on a one and probably a thousand
response rate right but if you actually
write to someone who's career then you
know so
take you talking about take a step back
we already think about how you can do
things and then like I said go above and
beyond if you know your key target
market well there's going to be demand
has got an event you got to get yourself
through the door you got to go out and
network well that's a good question but
if you think about it you can actually
quite easily get an invite so and that's
how you brand yourself okay because I
don't I believe now people need to be
more than just recruiters you need to be
a you know you need to be a consultant
and we have a thing at cusine car as we
work cradle to grave so we work in
placing candidates probably three or
four times throughout their journey yeah
but you know actually adding value to
the general market
place you know we work in the legal
industry so we actually want to add
value and and give back to the legal
industry so you know be there in the
form of article publications be that in
the form of you know hosting sponsoring
events do that in terms of doing fault
leadership you know do that in terms of
you know general what other campaigns
podcasts all of these great things
because now you can't just be a
recruiter you've got to be able to be
seen as someone okay I want to go and
speak to X because they're just an
expert in my area not gonna make me more
money how is that going to make you more
what depends what you define as what
what's important to you because I think
for me it's important to make money but
it's also to have a good recognition as
reputation if you build up your
reputation over the years the money will
also come okay I think that's very very
important so I think if people actually
see you similar to you know what what I
see from a lot of people if they're you
know really investing in their career
yeah and being seen as a real somebody
that does more than just recruitment
yeah I believe that all ten co-work
temple we have a thing is well here
where we say contacts are great but
relationships pay and I think that's
everyone can love and know everybody
right but actually any people like oh
it's not what you know it's who you know
mmm to an extent is who knows you and
who you have a relationship with okay so
you know that's why it's important and
that transfers to yeah that transfers to
you then long-term but I think it's
important to be an environment where
because some I can understand what
you're saying about making money and
it's just it becomes great but like how
does that increase my Billings to go I
mean that's why I'm absolutely but I
think yes we have to move away from
having a transactional view to my do you
know I want to be a consultative
longer-term relationship driven
recruiter and understand that I may not
get the win straightaway you know I may
not break down that Ford mentality
exactly so and that but it comes back to
when you're planning your days I'll be
amazed if every recruiter in London is
genuinely planning their days
particularly and being selfish with that
time because they should be because all
of this other stuff when you say is also
outside of ours right because your core
time you're going to be working smart
you're gonna be working small and you
know working warm so all the other stuff
the brown building and everything else
should just be an additional because you
care about your career
that's my viewpoint yeah okay that's
what it so how okay that's really
interesting really interesting point
that I mean that that's something that
I'm really passionate about nothing yeah
everyone listen what now has such a
unique opportunity to approach real
crewmen like that as you said like I'd
rather that up there everything that you
spoke about there is just I need to
enable - yeah we'll do more work because
when work but it's it also gives you
more of an interest point because
believe it or not people don't just like
to talk about recruitment you know if
you're looking from a business
development strategy and you're looking
at ways to communicate with your clients
and you're looking to try and add value
to them every agency's got candidates
yeah every agency's got canidates but
what can you tell them about the market
what can you tell them about the trends
what can you tell them about their
competitors what can you tell them
that's going to add value to them over
and beyond just providing the best
candidates in the marketplace and that
is where you'll build a long-term
trusting relationship yeah okay really
smart so one thing that I definitely
wanted to get you're experiencing so I
guess so
first year how was that like did you see
buildings that go okay or like what
what's been that how has that been yeah
so again I think and it's through blood
sweat and tears you know we are a growth
on growth year-on-year
business so what does that mean so that
means a it means I was prepared to put
skin in the game from from year one so
initial investments repaid plus profit
in year one yeah
year two 15% growth upon year one and
year three 33% grow so we've had
double-digit growth yeah year on year
since starting and that's because we've
we've fundamentally worked to the basic
principles of what works yeah exactly
and I think otherwise if you have such a
scattergun a lack of focus lack of
strategy and I was guilty of that as a
recruiter at my junior years where I was
just not focused then you know lo and
behold you're busy but you can't break
past a certain level yeah but my role
now and why I wasn't keen to get
involved in in these sort of discussions
is it's you move away from recruiter to
business builder
and recruitment owners yes and you know
there's an element of being involved in
recruitment but it's ultimately you know
you've got to bring the best out of the
people that work for you and with you
you know so I genuinely care about
everyone who works here and wants them
to do very very well yeah so I think
you've got a higher people that you want
to work with yeah and you know coach is
very very important and then you've got
to think about right how can you drive
the business day by day by day by day
and say yeah I've enjoyed my personal
journey and it's not been look there's
been ups and downs and they say because
obviously that's that's um like honest
amazing achievement but I I get messages
or people that they're just one-man band
they're sitting in their living room
right yeah sitting in the office like
yeah this is [ __ ] horrible this is no
more tougher than I thought it was
really testing my resilience or like
they should talk a bit about that
because like that's amazing that you've
achieved that but what was some of the
real tough times and how did you push
through those um I've had lots of tough
times and even day-to-day you have your
you know your your struggles but I think
one of the tips I'd give people is don't
just sit there in your living room find
mentors you know I've been very
proactive in you know putting my network
and getting into my network and really
finding new mentors that can help
inspire educate me and share their
journeys and it's not just necessary
recruitment business owners mentors
mentors and different you know maybe in
sales and insurance so finding people
who have got a proven track record of
being successful because mindsets very
very important yeah you know I you know
we've all been there you're having a
poor month or you've just started your
business you're in your living room
you're having a bit of a downer you're
doubting yourself whether you can do it
you know don't just do that you know
actually go out there be proactive
network find mentors and get sort of you
know get some ideas and really kind of
upskill yourself I find a lot of people
back to the commute and coasts and
stagnate you've got to find something
new if something's not working yes you
can kind of you know have a bit of a
down day but don't stay down you've got
to be proactive so you know go out there
and you know speak to good credible
people that can actually help you okay I
couldn't agree more I mean obviously I'm
what ten ten weeks in to start my own
business I've got two mentors yeah
definitely helped and I've had couple
other people that are really been
helpful but
I think again let's sort of break that
down a bit because people listen it's
like okay but definitely mental is such
a quite common word now right and it's
something on I'm definitely really
passionate about how what's your advice
to approach people and fight because yes
great saying go find his people but
where the [ __ ] do I find them how do I
approach them know that these people are
busy together I mean so what's been your
experience in finding and approaching
these people yeah I think again it comes
back to being proactive I think you've
got to be proactive and it's also I
don't just think you should find someone
who's been successful you got to make
sure that they're right for you so you
know if you actually follow there's so
much stuff publicly available now it
comes back to cutting corners you can
actually cut corners in terms of finding
mentors you can easily find anyone that
will give you some advice but if you
actually want to research and find
someone that you think can add value to
you and then target to them and then you
can write to them or call them with
genuine passion and enthusiasm for why
you want them to be your mentor and I
think that's very very important how
would you approach that so I think it's
so the way I've approached it actually I
believe I guess it's a recruiter me I'm
continuously working so one of my recent
mentors is actually through for a family
connection okay on my wife's side
someone who's run a successful business
and kind of why I'm using him
particularly for a mentor as he's
someone who scaled and exerted a
business yeah you know and then on
multiple occasions and sort of had a lot
of challenges along the way and done it
from an organic level and obviously
that's aspirations that I have yeah and
and look to do so you know I've been
able to sort of talk their language and
sort of you know I've made sure I've
muscled myself in on certain little
events or found even family things you
know it's going the extra mile it's
being prepared to you know drive 150
miles up to know that they're going to
be at a potential you know event where
you can have a kind of one-on-one chat
with them and but you know research
there's loads of things online there's
loads of events you can go to there's
lots and lots of things you can talk to
people if your recruitment owner you can
talk to other recruitment owners there's
no harm in that
you know talking to people so yeah
basically being proactive and then howl
and then how is it definitely how is it
most impacted you then like you know I
mean like what was because what what are
the was the
cool top relationship just again out of
complete curiosity maybe people listen
to an interested light does this then
you tend to check in with these people
once a month do you meet them if you
then say look these are the Chinese that
I'm having is it something you can
always check in with love what's the
typical relationship and how is it what
where would you say how is it most
impacted you in running your own
business I think it's most of mine tend
to be on a sort of formal quasi informal
basis so it's more about being there I
think you know if you're gonna find a
mentor I actually find someone who's
actually potentially gonna have a
genuine care for you you know sometimes
just being able to pick up the phone and
say you know I had this strategy it's
blown out of the water
it's all gone wrong actually just being
a voice you know someone you can talk to
and have an outlet but more structured
than that I think it's actually about
having you know some sort of regularity
so I tend to have monthly kind of
progressive you know discussions talks
around subjects areas you know
identifying problems and going to them
with solutions not just asking can you
help me it's like these are my ideas how
do you think we can improve them you
know that's the other thing you know
even when I do my own mentoring when I'm
mentoring people in recruitment or
another industry sectors I say don't
have come to me for expecting answers
come with some ideas and let's actually
discuss how we can improve them I think
that's very very important you then when
you say in a nutshell firstly it's been
very good for mental well-being in terms
of actually keeping positive and keeping
focused so I think it's been very very
good for that it's helped me in terms of
increasing profitability and
productivity of team members and it's
made it fun yeah it's good learning
about and hearing other people's
journeys and actually implementing new
things cuz then I love learning I think
you know in any industry you've got a
love to learn and so I love learning new
things and being open to learning
because you know when I when I first
started I was kind of shut off to the
whole idea of oh you know I know I know
now I don't need to know anything more
but that's so wrong yeah continuous
learning so that's how its really helped
me okay so before we finish there mate
mindset
yeah mentioning a couple of times yeah
what sort of what has been your journey
with that then and how clearly the
mentorship has helped but what's been
your journey with that and how
better to cultivate a mindset that
serves you rather than yeah leaves you
just being negative all day and not
being able to be productive and not
focus like however you cultivate that
and what's been your journey with that
yeah I mean it's been it's been very
interesting because I always thought
whether recruitment was for me you know
when I had the bad first year and I was
just you know I was doubting myself
most definitely I think sometimes pinch
yourself
I think people beat yourselves up you
know because you are an in competin you
know recruitment tends to be a
competitive environment but take a step
back and think actually what have I
achieved you know if you actually have
achieved you know celebrate those
successes so I think the one thing I
always say to people is celebrate the
little wins yeah you know to re may be
doing a deal or that annual target is so
far off and you're having a bad month
but actually no celebrate you know if
you break into a new client or you know
you win a candidate over that you
haven't been able to for the last two
months so for me whatever it is I've
always kind of celebrated the mini wins
to kind of keep me eternally positive
and so so important to surround yourself
with positive people you know and that's
as far to say as you know if you've got
a you've got a very frugal if you've got
an office for the negative people how do
you do that leave well I mean you can
either try and change the culture and
try and be positive but there's nothing
worse than being in a negative
environment with negative people because
that's you know there's a thing about
sort of you know group vine and you know
how that negativity can yeah basically I
can agree more so no I take action of
your own career you know if you're if
you feel like you're in a negative
environment it's bringing you down
either do your absolute best to try and
change it and raise it with management
and with directors and try and change it
around or leave yeah very simple I think
that's nothing that's fair I think
definitely I mean especially in the word
rule crewmen - it's bloody difficult
sometimes and then if if you're even
then if then people feeling even more
negativity yeah in this sort of ups and
downs leader experience and then that's
difficult right
I had another thing tip from one of my
old bosses that I thought was great as
well and they always had a kind of
shutoff mindset so every day we used to
say shoot from a 10 but you know she's
from a town shoot from a 10 every day
but the way they did that was in
no matter what was going on in their
personal life you know maybe the you
know having a relationship issue or
maybe they've got a health issue or
whatever but whenever they came on their
commute to work because they weren't a
commute and Coast person at all they
would say once I go past that rent post
box past the office on the way to the
office I forget about everything and I'm
hungry in shape I'm you know it's like
when we used to play sport back in the
day when you cross the whitewash you
come to play right or when you lace them
up you come to play so whatever's going
on you need to be able to have a
blockout mindset so I actually have
every day when I come to work when I go
past the particular building whatever is
going on in my life I shut it off and
it's like I need to shoot from a 10
today except I can shoot from a 10 today
and achieve my goals then I can be
productive because if all I'm doing is
dwelling on all those negative thoughts
it's bringing me down I'm unproductive
I'm influencing others with negativity
it's just a really really stubbe sø
that's just a tip that I got off someone
that I use in my day to day knifing
that's gray and what you're saying there
is that every single day be present yep
you know I mean that's pretty much like
any cartoon --'tis yeah yeah so it's
like everyday when you come to work it
generally is cliche but it is a new day
but it's another yeah it's a brand new
opportunity to exactly you know ask your
directors to go and shadow a meeting
that you never dream of asking him to do
you know ask someone to go snow push
yourself you know push yourself to
develop day to day and and you'll get
more satisfaction from it as well yeah
we commit well it before am I finish
always like to ask what sir what's going
on in your world mate
well shouting about we excited about a
society cusine car which I'm really
really excited about we're on a you know
a genuine journey and it's been an
absolute whirlwind and it in a positive
way um what else going on my world I'm
trying to get back fit
I used to he's played quite a lot of
sport competitively so I had a lot of
friends that you know represented the
country and rugby and cricket and did
very very well and that's actually been
sort of mentors from afar that I've
actually gone on to succeed so I'm
trying to get back fit how are you
finding that because that honestly I
think and then in the last ten weeks so
I've always been like alright yeah I'm
not gonna
okay but a lot I'm just classic I'll
just easily fluctuate six eight weeks
I'll be on there and then it will tell
our two weeks when well I'm not that on
that and then I'm back to [ __ ] square
one so like how is it have you found
I'll see maybe even in recruitment but
also just running around business there
I've definitely found that the last ten
weeks that that has definitely not
consciously but it's just ended up sort
of sacrificing a bit and I found it just
more difficult just easy excuse but like
how have you found that that must have
been has it been a bit of a challenge
there as you had been a bit of a
challenge but you know health is wealth
at the end of the game so you've got to
be able to you know you've got to be
able to be dedicated to doing it so it's
like everything you've got to set
yourself goals and recruitment drives
you we talked about the internal drive
you know I've set myself a goal that I
want to get to a certain way and I get
to touch a certain fitness again and
really really enjoy it and the other
thing it's back to work again but we're
doing some really high-profile events
coming up that I'm really excited about
in our in our Mark Callum quite a few
people mention event yeah but how are
they impacted your business so in a very
positive way back to the you said to me
well I'm a recruiter how can I get into
you know well like I've told you know we
discussed about building a brand and
actually getting your name through a
door through not being known as a
recruiter you know they've impacted our
business because the two events that
we're doing we're the only and we're the
first legal recruitment agency to
actually be involved in the societies
our because they typically say no
recruiters because they see us a
differently understand our message our
journey and so it's see they see us as
trusted advisors and they see us as
actually consultants and more than just
recruiters so it's impacted us in terms
of our branding being known as you know
a very relationship driven kind of you
know advisory outfit so it's been very
very positive and that's led to more
referrals more nations and more place
than the bottom line yeah exactly it's
got the referral is it's got the place
can I think I hear more and more about
events and I think it's so I think I
just really believe that recruiters are
in such a unique position to facilitate
great events put some amazing people in
the room if that's from a candidate
perspective being able to have access to
some brilliant decision-makers and
senior people and businesses that you
know that they never dreamed of getting
access to or learning
their perspective of the market in these
things I think recruiting is such a
great position to facilitate that
there's so many resources out there now
it's very true so the other thing I'm
trying trying to publicize is now job
specs are old-fashioned job specs are
old-fashioned so why are we not getting
our clients to you know go when you go
and meet them let's do some video specs
right we're doing video interviews why
we're not flipping at the other side you
know and actually showing off our
clients you know and actually that sort
of imagery and stuff like that there's
so many new quirky innovative things I
mean that's not that overly emotive but
there's so much more people can do with
resources available now just go for it
yeah nice I like it so question I always
like to ask mate and before we finish is
if you could communicate to every single
recruiter out there
they take on your advice they would
listen they'd start using your advice
tomorrow what do you say if you see this
as a career I would generally say never
ever ever ever give up and I think
that's you know you've got to be
prepared to go through the through the
hard times and there's an extension of
that is you've got to be prepared to
improve yourself day by day so if you're
coming to work day by day and you're not
looking at how you're improving and
you're hitting the same kpi's or you're
hitting the same targets then you've got
to really take a step back and analyze
that and really think about how you can
improve and I always say surround
yourself by the best people never be the
best person in the room like I'm not
today the master of podcast next to me
but in all seriousness you know surround
yourself by very very aspirational you
know strong people with a high achievers
because that will bring the best out in
you amazing it's been a pleasure
cool thanks ever so much isn't it